[Música]
si te digo coronavirus que viene al
mente
ok seguramente medicamentos hospitales
enfermedad sin embargo yo te voy a decir
algo totalmente diferente con la virus
en realidad es un acelerador
es un acelerador del cambio y no de
cualquier cambio es un acelerador del
cambio exponencial necesario de la
humanidad y por qué te digo esto digamos
que cuando menos los últimos 50 años nos
llegamos a asumir el impacto de la
tecnología en la vida y hoy hablaremos
particularmente de su impacto en la
educación
digamos que en educación los últimos 20
años simple y llanamente no volteamos a
mirar el impacto tecnológico ni tampoco
entendimos de qué manera es que se
desarrolla porque hablamos de cambio
exponencial porque la tecnología se
desarrolla en dos líneas
fundamentalmente es decir hay un
desarrollo tecnológico una base
tecnológico y ese mismo avance
tecnológico empuja el siguiente avance
tecnológico a una velocidad
extraordinaria
por supuesto que conlleva un impacto de
alguna manera para todos ha sido
complicado y te voy a decir por qué
porque fue más cómodo adoptar una serie
de mitos a partir de los cuales simple y
llanamente podríamos obviar la
existencia de la tecnología consideramos
que no era necesaria no era importante
en muchos casos en el campo educativo
y nos creamos al menos 2002 1 inmigrante
digital
es ideal estamos convencidos en este
momento es que vibrante y digital no
existe no existe porque simple y
llanamente nos vendimos la idea de la
misma televisión y no consideramos que
la tecnología es interactiva y es
precisamente la interactividad lo que
modificó los patrones de relación de los
chicos con la tecnología y nosotros
pensamos que no estaban haciendo de la
manera correcta pero no hay una gran
diferencia entre nacer con un principio
de lo que es la tecnología y saber donde
manipularla para poder tener una
respuesta y yo otra condición totalmente
diferente es el uso de la tecnología
para la enseñanza y el aprendizaje
y en este proceso de emergencia de
migrar el aula a la casa lo que nos
encontramos es que finalmente tampoco
sus papás saben utilizar la tecnología
para el aprendizaje es decir bajo ese
mito dejamos correr cuando menos cuatro
generaciones y hoy la problemática
pudiera parecer mucho más complicada sin
embargo del otro lado nos vendimos
también el mito del inmigrante digital y
la perspectiva de migrantes sería como
no tomar responsabilidad por lo que
implicaba el uso de la tecnología y la
trascendencia de ésta particularmente en
la impresión
simple y llanamente eso justificó haber
hecho de no asumirla como una necesidad
personal y entonces seguramente desde
tus clases lo que hicimos fue llamar a
pedir toda paliza para que nos ayudara a
manejar la tecnología de la misma manera
dentro de los mismos esquemas educativos
es decir tradicionales
y desde estas dos perspectivas sumamos
además el asunto de la idea de
irresponsabilidad
y si previamente no asumimos que no
asumimos lo que teníamos que hacer ese
momento y desde ahí nos permitimos
serios responsables sin embargo esta
charla no se trata de cualquier otra
cosa sino se trata de estar por la
oportunidad
y la oportunidad en este momento es
comprender que no hay una anormalidad a
la cual regresar a la normalidad la
vamos a construir todos y que crees que
dentro de ese campo de nueva normalidad
lo fundamental será la educación y dime
tú sino a decir de la onu 1.6 mil
millones de jóvenes y niños quedaron
fuera de los procesos educativos en el
primer momento considera que eso se va
incrementando se va a incrementar en
términos de la posibilidad o no de los
de las problemáticas que han saltado al
escenario conectividad y acceso a la
tecnología
además considera que esta migración de
los procesos enseñanza-aprendizaje
a la casa está conllevando también la
generación de nuevas brechas de
conocimiento de desarrollo cognitivo de
aprendizaje particularmente en las
generaciones más pequeñas
eso al menos nos llevaría 20 años y algo
que no tenemos solís tiempo entonces
simplemente vamos a asumir
que la realidad
separarme
y así es hoy la mayoría de nuestras
operaciones y acciones se realizan a
través del internet estamos trabajando
desde casa compramos luego las cosas
desde el internet estamos haciendo pagos
y estamos haciendo transacciones y
estamos llevando a la vida cotidiana
muchas de las actividades al xi del
espacio y eso no va a cambiar no hay
manera de regresar nuestro esquema
por lo tanto tenemos que asumir que el
reto es precisamente llevar el uso de la
tecnología al campo educativo desde dos
líneas o desde dos perspectivas primero
hacer sustentable la tecnología esto
quiere decir que aprendamos a utilizarla
de manera heurística es decir que aporte
y desarrollo todo el poder que tiene
porque la tecnología se creó
fundamentalmente para el desarrollo
total de la inteligencia del potencial
humano solamente se nos olvidó un
pequeño detalle entonces es el momento
de dar un paso atrás y generar una
relación distinta con la tecnología para
también hacerla sostenible es decir
hacemos utilizada para lo que
creada para desarrollar el potencial
humano y por el otro lado garantizar que
ese formato ese esquema de abuso
permanezca prevalezcan en el tiempo de
tal manera que no hay más no hay más que
en soltar las maneras de educar este
tiempo esquema victoriano más allá de
200 años que se fortaleció y se
estructuró perfectamente para el mundo
industrial ya no existe tampoco entonces
no hay más que mirar hacia nuevas
prácticas
simplemente porque en esa nueva
normalidad de aquí en adelante la
escuela tendrá que ser híbrida y
adaptativa qué quiere decir esto
la escuela tendrá que aprender a
trabajar en dos escenarios a distancia y
el niño
a distancia y presencial que estamos
diciendo con esto en el esquema
presencial se trabajará necesariamente
desde el desarrollo de proyectos el
aprendizaje desde una perspectiva
transversal multidisciplinar
inclusive transdisciplinares así en
general conocimiento de fronteras porque
porque le daremos a los chicos la
oportunidad de resolver los grandes
problemas de la humanidad sabiendo
utilizar la tecnología para encontrar la
información que necesita crear
soluciones y porque en gavà apostarle
también a que la creación de esas
soluciones a los problemas de la
humanidad puedan ser rentables y de 70
mientras manera de desarrollar su
emprendimiento porque considera que
y hoy se está modificando mucho más allá
de lo que estaba previsto
es decir ellos tendrán que crear su
propio trabajo su propia aportación
entonces desde ahí
la parte disciplinaria del conocimiento
la estaremos trabajando
y de manera presencial trabajaremos
todas las otras áreas que necesitan de
la interacción humana de qué estamos
hablando estaremos trabajando en el
ámbito socio emocional las
comunicaciones las relaciones las artes
y por supuesto los deportistas entonces
pues simple y llanamente vayamos dando
la oportunidad de subirnos a cambio al
cien por ciento dejar atrás los
paradigmas cualquiera que haya sido o se
te muestro o cualquier otro y entonces
simple y llanamente empezar a fluir en
el contexto así mira no quiero que te
vayas sin nada y te quiero hablar de lo
que podrían ser los cinco pasos para
la transición educativa y porque te
hablo de transición educativa porque
precisamente en este momento no
solamente es el empuje de la necesidad
de cambio sino también hablar ya de una
transición educativa es decir una acción
educativa que anglada los objetivos para
el desarrollo sostenible la agenda 2030
nos pueda ayudar un mapa de ruta para
alcanzar los aprendizajes necesarios el
uso adecuado de la tecnología para
avanzar al hacer lo que sería el mundo
de la cuarta revolución industrial
y qué crees que da pena 2030 ya no nos
da 19 años para alcanzarla simplemente
la aceleración del cambio nos está
empujando a pensar en 5 años no más por
las brechas existentes y por las que se
van generando en el proceso entonces
pues hay quienes los 5 pasos
a ser un educador que impulse esa
transición educativa y que nos coloque
en el siglo 21 al 100% primero de verdad
suelta saberlo todo en la era de la
información y la comunicación no es
posible saber todo definitivamente no lo
que podemos aspirar es simplemente a
encontrar la información correcta la más
avanzada y trabajar con ella lo otro
miramos crear comunidad poner los
paradigmas de la docencia ha sido
trabajar solo eso no funciona entonces
aprendamos a trabajar en comunidad de
manera colaborativa
nos tenemos que dar permiso de
retroalimentar y recibir
retroalimentación de estar por lo que
funciona por lo que nos da lo que
necesitamos y lo que entrega a los niños
y los jóvenes lo que requiere
entonces aprendamos a fluye a fluye y
ese es nuestro paso número 3
a fluir en que en la realidad en el
cambio en la contingencia en el
certidumbre de la complejidad de la
transformación permanente eso lo vamos a
detener va a ser el motor de la vida en
el mundo de aquí en adelante y lo otro
de verdad cuarto paso es bien importante
aprendamos a correr riesgos fluir nos
lleva de verdad dejar de controlar
corremos el riesgo con esas esposas
diferente porque algo está aprobado
mucho más allá de cualquier mortal y es
el hecho de que si no transformamos lo
que hacemos siempre llanamente
seguiremos obteniendo los mismos
resultados y peor con una mayor carga o
equivocación
5 dirigente considera que este es un
escenario inédito la humanidad jamás ha
estado ni en el vacío jamás confrontó la
humanidad de nuestro texto global una
situación en la condición como la que
estamos ahora y que que es cuando menos
los próximos dos o tres años estaremos
igual entonces yo a lo que te invito es
de verdad hay que divertirse ser ligeros
livianos frente a cambio y darnos la
oportunidad verdaderamente de ser la
generación que haga una diferencia
tomando responsabilidad por lo que hay y
asumiendo el riesgo de que el ser humano
siga siendo simple y llanamente
de la vida de la historia en una
perspectiva holística donde la vida
importa el mundo importa y todos los
seres vivos nos podemos unir y
transformar traer fuerza de esta
situación ok
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]